a new report sheds light on the events
surrounding a controversial photo op by
president trump last year park police
helped clear
washington's lafayette park not long
before the president walked across it to
stand in front of a church
they were accused of abusing american
citizens to help president trump look
good
chris van cleef was there that day and
he joins us now chris good morning to
you what's in this report
well good morning the clearing of the
park and the area that is now known as
black lives matter plaza happened ahead
of a city-wide curfew and came as a
surprise to many of the people there
including other law enforcement now this
department of the interior inspector
general report found the decision to
move the crowd back was made
hours before u.s park police leadership
learned of the president's photo op
where he held up a bible
park police told the ig the decision was
made to move the crowd further from the
white house to allow a vendor to come in
to install security fencing around
lafayette park and that came after a
weekend where there was
violent unrest in the city we were there
in the middle of the crowd that
stretched for blocks from what we could
see this was
a peaceful demonstration the city was
under a 7 p.m curfew but the police
moved in aggressively about 30 minutes
early the report says there were three
announcements
to disperse we heard none of those our
first warning was the sound of
flashbangs
and officers in riot gear rushing our
location
the report references then attorney
general bill barr who was on scene
during part of the protests
saying to a park police commander are
these people still going to be here
when potus the president comes out now
this is what bill barr said
about that on face the nation last june
i gave the green light at two o'clock
obviously i didn't know
that the president was going to be
speaking later that day
now this report does challenge the
narrative that the white house had the
protesters cleared solely for a photo op
but it
is narrow in scope it was done by the
department of the interior it was
focused on the park police response it
did not include interviews with former
trump officials like bill barr
and of course there are lingering
questions including that decision to
move in
before the curfew during what appeared
to be a largely
peaceful protest gail all right chris
thank you very much